Janet Jackson pulls out some big
surprises for her la tour stop Plus Lady
Gaga shares a rare photo with boyfriend
Christian Kirino everybody hope you guys
had a great weekend let me tell you last
night was a big night in Hollywood as
Janet Jackson descended upon the
Hollywood Bowl for a special homecoming
the 51 year old new mama showed off how
much work she's been putting in that gym
rocking a skin-tight black cat suit nine
months after baby it was her first and
only la stop for her state of the world
world tour she marked the occasion by
reuniting dozens of her former backup
dancers onstage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I like to pretend on one of Janet's
dancers I know I'm not but you know who
is Channing Tatum's wife Jenna Dewan who
danced on Janet's all for you tour 16
years ago tonight witness says Channing
was in the box he's cheering his wifey
on and Jenna was instagramming all night
but she wasn't alone new voice coach
Jennifer Hudson was living her best life
watching Janet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right J HUD get it I was not
there so I have been literally living
vicariously through everybody's feeds
and Instagram stories but clearly miss
Jackson still got it now well without
Janet there would be no Beyonce in a
world without Beyonce is when I want no
part in Queen and the rest of the royal
Carter family spent the weekend at a
friend's wedding in New Orleans we of
course stunned in her peachy flowy gown
but check out Blue Ivy who is clearly
following in her mom's stylish footsteps
and get this Blue Ivy's wedding look was
a hand sewn Mishka aoki dress covered in
crystals and retails for $5,000 ask me
how much this denim jacket cost huh help
me I'm poor blue and her daddy jay-z
also shared this sweet father/daughter
moment during the celebration
and as if we needed more proof that Blue
Ivy is Beyonce's mini-me on Saturday B's
mom miss Tina shared this friggin
adorable throwback photo of a young
Beyonce getting her hair braided
Tina captioned the pic if B honestly
don't look like Blu in this photo and I
say uncanny if you ask me miss Tina
alright meanwhile Lady Gaga is also
posting up a storm but for a good cause
mother Monster shared a rare selfie with
boyfriend Christian Kirino who she
referred to as a very special someone as
he leans on her shoulder the sweet photo
comes with a bit of sadness as Gaga paid
tribute to her friend Sonya Durham who
lost her battle with breast cancer in
May Saturday would have been her
birthday gaga wrote after rolling around
on the couch feeling sad with the help
of some of my Grigio girls and a very
special someone I managed to dress up
and feel better in a beautiful pink
sequined dress generously gifted to me
from Oscar de la Renta Sonia would want
us to celebrate her birthday so we are
pink is the official color of Breast
Cancer Awareness Month which takes place
every October Gaga and her boyfriend
mark the occasion wearing pink and
handing out pink or she kisses are
switching gears to my one-on-one with
Tia Mari
she joined us in studio for a Facebook
live chat and let me tell you she is one
of the most fun interviews ever and
while she was here I just had to find
out where things stand with the
long-awaited Sister Sister reboot how
many fans are jonesing for Sister Sister
ability update what can you tell us you
know I will say this we are definitely
closer than ever
like that's basically all I can say but
I'm getting excited and I will say that
I feel like the fans are even making me
even more excited they're like rooting
me on I'm like okay wow you guys want
this okay we're gonna make it happen you
know so we're getting close yeah the
rest of the cast be involved if it did
come back um yes as I as I know of now
you know definitely jackée Harry and Tim
Reid will definitely be a part of the
show
mom that girl is my face if it does
happen given any thoughts of where the
story would pick up I think I would want
it to kind of pick up with where our
lives are now we're married with kids
but I think I would definitely want it
to focus on the power of a sisterhood
mm-hmm you know how wonderful and
amazing that sisterhood in that
relationship can be and family because
family is so important to me while we
wait for that Sister Sister reboot Tia
is now sharing life hacks with families
on her new youtube series Tia marries
quick fix she's got everything from
quick hair fixes sheet pan dinners and
other shortcuts your life needs you can
find out more about her series our full
interviews up now on ET online.com thank
you guys so much for watching and while
you're here be sure to hit subscribe on
e t--'s youtube channel so you don't
miss an episode of the daily Denny like
comment share and I will see you guys
tomorrow I'm gonna Rhythm Nation out of
here